foreign
[Music]
Hall where later this month we'll host
the pi data Amsterdam conference over 80
experienced speakers will take this
stage Amsterdam is back and this year
bigger than ever at this beautiful
location in the center of Amsterdam so
what I really like the connections that
are being built the knowledge that is
being shared that you watched it one
keynote and you get that idea and you
bring it back home but you become even
better at what you do and you become a
true master in this old Shipyard it was
actually in the 18th century
containers shipping machine learning to
production
catch up on the latest trends in machine
learning data science it will be all
here experienced practitioners sharing
stories and learning from their projects
as well as core contributors explaining
how to use the tools you use on a
day-to-day basis get hyped because we
have the most insane schedule with four
tracks envelopes causal inference large
language modeling something for everyone
we use open source tooling such that you
can directly apply the learnings in your
own data project join us
if you didn't get enough there are also
the drinks where the true connections
are being built see you there
[Music]